- You're gonna have to let
me try to do this, okay?
Hi, I am trying (baby
cries), oh here we go.
So I am trying to (baby cries).
Uh.
(instrumental music)
- So breast feeding in public
can be a little bit awkward.
Sometimes difficult.
- There's this huge stigma towards
breast feeding in public,
which is ridiculous.
This woman got screamed at by
another woman at a Whole Foods,
for breast feeding and I thought
that was really weird, because
there isn't a more whole food.
- So yeah, I saw this clothing line,
LeChe Libre dresses on Facebook.
And I saw that it went viral, I got
really excited about checking it out.
- Giving birth is the most powerful
thing a human body can do.
New moms really deserve to own
and celebrate the power of their body.
If they choose to breast feed,
they're continuing on in that power.
So I created LeChe Libre because I
really want to give women clothing
so they can celebrate and own their
power through fierce functional fashion.
- I wanna try this because it's
supposed to make breast feeding on
the go a little bit easier.
I got four kids, so I'm always on the go.
- I've been trying
really hard to find cute,
fun, sexy, functional clothing to wear
while I'm breast feeding my child
and often times I'm
wearing things like this.
It's just like, I have a
bathing suit underneath and
sometimes I'm a little overexposed
and I would like to have something
that's a little bit more classy.
- I like hanging out in sweatshirts,
but nobody wants to really lift their
whole fat side out, when they have
to nurse a baby, so if this
helps a little bit, then great!
I'm excited.
- Okay.
I'm gonna go ahead and open up the package
and see what the dress looks like.
- Definitely looks comfortable.
It looks like a sweatshirt.
- Here I am, wearing the LeChe Libre.
It's really cute.
- All right here's the full thing.
- It's definitely comfortable
(zippers zipping).
This feels a little weird (laughs).
- The only thing is, it's very short.
Look at this. When I put my shoes on.
I mean, it's cute. It's fun.
- So, I'm just right now going to
whip it out and feed the
baby, now that it's on me.
- Let's go to the restaurant and
give it a try (zipper zips).
- I decided to try out some public
breast feeding at the park.
- A little bit of figuring
out how to finagle.
- Okay. Let's be honest.
Most of the time we really can't go out.
I love my daughter, but I
don't like the limitations.
But I do like the fact that if I did
wanna go out, and even though I tried
to go out in the past hour, and I got all
dressed up to go to the
stupid pharmacy, and I can't.
I have a nice dress on.
My husband went, "ooh
look, she looks kinda hot.
"Maybe I'll make a second baby with her."
- Some ladies are nervous,
public breast feeding.
Understandably so, and this does
make things a little bit easier.
- I'm sweating now.
Did they tell you that you
sweat when you breast feed?
- Children screaming. Did you know that?
That they, while they're eating,
they're not full enough at the moment
that they have the food
going in them (baby cries).
Sorry.
I love this dress. It's really cute.
And it's good with my skin tone.
It looks nice with some,
kind of red lipstick.
And it looks nice when the
baby's attached to you.
- I will use it this fall and this winter.
I'm liking it while I'm
at the park with my kids.
It's a go from us.
- A couple more inches at the bottom,
this would be a very functional
and super cool, and sexy,
and fun outfit to wear,
so that I could go out, look
cute and still feed my baby.
- She's so cute. You're so cute.
- I'm just the cutest.